[Musique]
si on a recours à un sapin naturel au
fil des jours qui passent il va se
dessécher donc essayer de l'humidifier
régulièrement parce que la moindre
étincelle ou source d'énergie est
susceptible d'enflammer les épines un
feu de de sapin c'est une véritable
torchère le sapin va s'enflammer en
quelques secondes et rapide ement les
fumées vont envahir la totalité de la
pièce et des volumes qui sont des fumées
toxiques et c'est vraiment le le le
danger
principal l'autre danger lié à cette
période festive qui doit le rester ce
sont parfois l'usage de bougies
décorativ à flamme nu donc ça c'est
idéalement c'est vraiment à proscrire
parce que c'est extrêmement dangereux
d'abord c'est les enfants peuvent se
brûler et ensuite ça peut être à
l'origine d'un d' un incendie
accidentel éviter la surcharge des
installations électriques euh et surtout
ne jamais brancher une multiprise sur
une autre multiprise euh à force ça va
occasionner une surchauffe euh des
éléments et des conducteurs électriques
qui risquent d'être à l'origine d'un
incendie dans les cadeaux euh on peut
trouver au pied du sapin euh peut-être
une trottinette électrique euh auquel
cas il faut être très vigilant sur la
façon avec laquelle on va charger la
batterie qui alimente cette trottinette
he qui est une batterie à base de
lithium euh qui euh peut s'avérer
extrêmement dangereuse et être à
l'origine d'incendie absolument
dramatique euh dont le développement euh
est très très violent euh et par
conséquent il faut absolument lorsque
vous allez mettre en charge cette
batterie illon le faire dans des
conditions de sécurité euh et surtout ne
jamais le faire dans l'entrée de votre
logement par exemple hein quand vous
habiter dans un appartement ne jamais
mettre en charge euh cette batterie et
cette trottinette à l'entrée de votre
logement tout simplement parce que s'il
y a un dysfonctionnement et que euh
c'est un départ de feu avéré vous allez
vous bloquer et vous empêcher la
possibilité d'évacuer votre logement euh
et vous retrouvez piégé par les fumées
et les flammes et et malheureusement
vous risquez vous risquez d'être victime
de de de cet incendie absolument
dramatique surtout se mettre en sécurité
le plus vite possible donc sortir de son
logement si le l'incendie vient se
déclarer chez soi bien penser à fermer
la porte toutes les portes que vous
pouvez fermer derrière vous c'est très
très important ça permet de de limiter
la propagation de l'incendie à la fois à
l'intérieur de votre logement mais aussi
dans un bâtiment d'habitation quand vous
habitez un appartement des é que
l'incendie ne se propage dans l'escalier
puis à d'autres artements c'est ça c'est
essentiel et puis bien sûr une fois que
vous êtes en sécurité vous et votre
famille composer le 18 vous allez tomber
sur la la salle des saports pompiers qui
vont se mettre en route extrêmement
rapidement et venir vous assister dans
ce dans ce
[Musique]
sinistre